hi i'm chris lovett and i work in the
microsoft research lab in redmond
in this webinar i'll explain the coyote
project
and walk through some example code
coyote is a dot-net framework and
testing tool that can help you solve
problems with concurrency
and non-determinism in the state
machinery
of your code this project is
brought to you by these three people
fantasies in akash
and the code is available on github
software developers are struggling to
manage the complexity of their code
especially as things are becoming more
and more asynchronous
also as we move into the world of
microservices engineers are being asked
to ship more frequently
in a world that is more and more
distributed
at the same time this complexity results
in more bugs
and as businesses including microsoft
deliver more of their mission critical
systems in the cloud
bugs in this code result in serious
revenue loss
so this makes it even more critical that
we do everything we can to
improve the state of the art for
engineering these systems
coyote guides developers into building
rock solid highly parallel code
let me illustrate
this animation shows messages passing
through a highly parallel distributed
system
each node represents a micro service or
a piece of code running on some machine
messages are flying through the system
in a way that makes it really hard to
debug
when something goes wrong coyote tests
one async path
at a time exploring all possible paths
through the system
and it does this very quickly it also
records this path so that when it finds
a bug
that bug is a hundred percent
reproducible
that's still pretty abstract so let me
show you something
that is a real system
this is an implementation of a complex
fault tolerant cluster protocol
called raft here you see five servers in
green all communicating with each other
as they implement the protocol to elect
a cluster leader each server runs in
parallel with respect to the others
so that the messages are flying around
as you can see here
as you can imagine this sort of thing is
really hard to debug
coyote can help break this down into
something that's testable
and debuggable
first you use the coyote framework to
declare your message types
and your state machines which are the
groups here
and the states inside each machine so we
see four states here
you also declare what are the valid
events that can be received in each
state
then you write a coyote test and run it
using the coyote test tool
in test mode coyote takes over control
of all concurrency and non-determinism
in your code
and all possible timings of events
in this asynchronous system and let me
show you what that looks like again
if i play that you can see it playing
one message at a time
so career is able to test your system
and visualize the results this is one
test iteration containing one specific
ordering of thousands of messages
through the system
in this case cody found a bug where two
of the servers in this cluster become
the cluster leader at the same time and
that's these red
nodes here which is actually a problem
that violates the
protocol the really cool thing is that
when coyote found this bug it also
recorded the exact message ordering
that was required to create that bug so
you can replay the bug
instantly in your debugger and you can
actually debug it without a million
different
threads going on at the same time so
when you use coyote to build these kinds
of distributed applications
you get for free a powerful testing tool
that can intelligently test your code
and find bugs automatically
even better when coyote found a bug like
this it's also 100 reproducible
the animation you just saw is also
greatly slowed down
just so that we can see what's going on
here the coyote tester itself
can run hundreds of these iterations per
second
making it possible to search the
enormous space of possibilities
to find even the most difficult bugs so
this is like a
search problem and microsoft research
has provided some built-in search
algorithms to help narrow down the
search for bugs
these have been tested and verified with
real customers working on large code
bases
so who's using coyote several teams in
azure are using coyote to build their
production services already
including various teams in azure batch
azure blockchain and azure compute
for example a team in azure batch is
using coyote to be able to check the
correctness of their failover logic
and the azure batch team has over a
hundred thousand lines of code using
coyote framework
another team in azure compute used
coyote to help them move to a much more
responsive and asynchronous design which
enabled the
coyote luck free event based active
programming model
and they actually got not only a
better system using coyote you know what
a system they could debug more easily
but
their final system actually performed
better as well which is really
interesting
all these customers are reporting
significant improvement to productivity
and confidence that their systems are
ready for production
each time they make a change
so coyote provides two programming
models
one is based on the task
programming model which is built on the
net framework task
platform the second programming model is
a more advanced actor programming model
using events
and state machines and i will show you
both of these programming models with
some examples
first the task model this programming
model offers a task
type that serves as a drop-in
replacement for the
native.net system threading task
tasks represent an asynchronous
operation
and integrates really nicely with the
c-sharp feature
async and await
in production a coyote task executes
with the same semantics as the
net task in fact it's a very thin
wrapper around the
native task which means it has a very
minimal overhead
in production during testing however
is where the magic happens and coyote
can take over
the execution of all tasks
during the test and can explore various
different interleavings between
the scheduling of all those tasks to
help find bugs
this model is in preview and is
available right now
so let's take a look at some code that
uses the task programming model
as is always the tradition with this
sort of thing is to show the simplest
possible hello world tasks
example this code is available in github
so i'm going to go over there i have the
repo right here
and i'm going to load hello world tasks
into visual studio all right here we see
a simple console application with a
program
and a main entry point and we see that
we have a class called
greeter
the greeter looks like a normal c sharp
class with an async
method called write with delay async
it simply sets a member field after some
delay is the setter
the run async method starts five
separate tasks
on purpose to make them run in parallel
calling that async method
then it uses this construct here on task
to wait for
all five of those tasks to complete
then it writes out the final value
that was set clearly this is setting up
a race condition
where the value will be randomly set to
one of these
two different strings depending on which
task gets scheduled
last in this up in this parallel
operation
so to finish this sample we write an
assert here
in this case we wrongly assert that the
final value after running these five
tasks
will always be hello world clearly
that's not
always going to be true because we have
one that sets it to good morning
so we've injected a bug into this code
on purpose
and let's run it and see what happens
i went ahead and built that and let me
run this version here
in window
right off the bat it hit the bug but
let's run it again and again
again you can see it sort of randomly
succeeds
or fails depending on that thread
scheduling
so this is basically the definition of a
non-deterministic bug
and you'll see that the coyote website
talks a lot about non-determinism
because that's one of the things that
coyote can be really good at helping
you test so what i'm going to do is show
you how to run this program
in the coyote test tool but before i do
that let me just show you
how that's going to work back in the
main
program you'll see that there's a coyote
test attribute
on this execute method this test
attribute
allows the coyote test tool to test this
program
in a special test mode the coyote test
tool
lives in the coyote repo if you built
the
coyote source code
this is building the coyote project from
source
and what we see is it's building all of
the coyote runtime
projects here including the coyote test
tool that we're going to use to test our
hello world
application there's the coyote test tool
being built right there
that's the one we'll use
now we go back to the samples folder
we're going to use that coyote test tool
if you just hit
enter here it shows you all the command
line arguments that you can pass
to this tool including
what you're testing which is passed as
an assembly
path so we're going to test
what we just built in the bin folder
we have to pick the same.net platform
dotnet 46 hello world
tasks and we'll do 100 test iterations
and we'll see if it can find a bug
so as expected because the bug was hard
coded into this program
when we run this in the kardi test tool
we
need a bunch of iterations which is what
i passed in the command line there
and then it hits the bug so it did seven
iterations in this case
and then it found a bug which is
reported found one bug
and it provides a log file that tells
you exactly what happened
when that test failed so let's look at
that
here you can see the log file says the
value is good morning instead of hello
that's because of the failed assert it
also gives you the stack trace
of where that bug was found in your
program which can be handy
now the interesting thing is that it
also provides a schedule
on how it created that bug
and this is where the real magic happens
with coyote
so this is what you can do is you can
actually instead of
test is a sort of search for bugs but
you can replay
that schedule replay will jump straight
to
the bug so you say replay
oh i have to give it the schedule
and instantly it found the bug it didn't
have to search this time it's actually
got the bugger ready i can even run that
with a break command which will put us
on a break point inside visual studio
and we can start debugging this thing
with 100
certainty that that bug will happen
so this is really huge for for those of
you who've spent
way too much time you know debugging
these sorts of problems with
multi-threading it can be extremely time
consuming i've spent
you know days trying to find a really
nasty multi-threading bug
and coyote actually makes these things
debuggable you know quickly
100 reproducible uh super useful
feature of coyote
there are some challenges with tasks
which i'll walk through here which is
that
when you write more code let me go back
to visual studio when you write a bigger
program
like the coffee machine example that
we'll look at in a little bit
oftentimes you'll find yourself
especially if you have a lot of
multi-threading going on you'll find
yourself having to use the lock
statement
with some sort of sync object and you
now have to you know
protect the update of local state
from multi-threading issues well the
lock statement
is interesting if i call out to some
other method
i now have to worry about
deadlocks if i had call a method and
that method starts another async task
that and waits for it that async task
then
calls back into this object and that
tries to lock i have a deadlock
deadlocks are also difficult to debug
so the other thing is that when you have
all this async code and you need locks
you
can't use the await keyword inside
in fact the intellisense is not even
letting me because it's not allowed
you're not allowed to use a weight
inside a lock
because that can be also a guarantee for
deadlocks
so there are some non-trivial aspects to
writing
thread safe code that you run into if
you have a lot of parallel tasks
in your programs deadlocks
can't use async and you have to protect
your your state
so async methods our powerful feature of
c-sharp async await is a really cool
thing
but you have to be careful um there are
complications
so this leads us to the other
programming model that coyote provides
which is an actor-based
programming model and there's actually a
lot of computer science research
into active programming models that show
some great advantages of using
this model the first thing that we do
with actors
is you cannot call them directly you
have to send events to them
and that goes through an inbox so each
actor has an inbox that's kind of like
email right so you send a message to an
actor
and you cannot call methods directly on
the actor the only thing you have is an
id
which is the uh thing that you need to
send a message to an actor
that's the actor id and an event is like
think of an event as as a bundle of
method parameters that are
wrapped up in an object called an event
and that's what you send to the
actor but that event then is something
that can live outside of any call stack
unlike method parameters
that are always on a call stack an event
can just live forever in
an inbox independent of call stacks
there's a lot of information on
wikipedia about this programming model
and how it came about it's very popular
in this
world of distributed systems
so events can also easily be serialized
uh to create a distributed system so now
your
events are actually going across the
wire to other systems
so what we do with actors in coyote
is we run each actor
in a separate thread or task but the
actor only dequeues and processes one
event at a time which means the actor
internal implementation doesn't need to
worry about multi-threading so we don't
need to do any locks
which is why we we said that azure batch
got a performance improvement because
they were doing
lock free programming basically and the
parallelism happened at a higher level
instead of
doing parallelism at the method level
you're doing it at the actor level
that actually greatly simplifies your
programming model it's a little bit
similar to asp.net that says
you could process one http request at a
time here an actor
processes one event at a time
it's a lock free programming model so
let's take a look at the simplest
possible
active program
hello world so again that's
uh here in github and we'll load that
into visual studio hello world actors
right here
has a very similar program with a main
entry point
and a greater class except this time
the greeter class is an actor
and you can see that this actor
is provided by the coyote actor
namespace so with actors
you declare what types of events can be
received
with a custom attribute this says that
the greeter is expecting to receive
a request for greetings
in this event type what we can then do
is go to the definition of an event
event is also provided by the coyote
namespace
and here you can put data inside your
events
so here we've got one piece of data that
we're sending
which is the id of the caller so the
caller is calling
the greeter requesting that their
greater return
a greeting the greeter will return this
event down here
which is another event which contains a
greeting just as a string
so this is how you bundle these events
into various event objects and you can
now send them
to the actor so you declare what type of
event you can receive
or handle so this actor can handle
request greeting events
and this tells you uh tells coyote what
method to call
when that event is received so it's
going to call handle greeting
right here and we can cast that back to
the type we're expecting
and we can pull the we can create a
greeting
using a random choice between hello
world and good morning
so this is actually going to choose
randomly between those two
random number generation is also
provided by the actor base class
because coyote wants to actually be
involved
in the generation of random numbers at
test time
the greeter then simply does a send
event
to send the greeting back to the caller
which is provided in this event and
with a chance of one and ten so that's
what
random bullion ten means a one in ten
chance
it's going to send a second greeting and
this is our bug in this case
we're injecting a bug in here on purpose
that sends too many
greetings back to the caller
all right so how do you test an actor
over in the program
we have another class
called a test actor
and the test actor is going to act like
a client if you like of the greeter so
the test actor has to
call has to create the greeter and call
send event requesting
a greeting so this is how we test our
greeter
by creating the actor again what we get
back here is not
an instance of a c sharp object we don't
ever have permission
to see the real instance of this object
that's created by the coyote runtime
and this ensures a proper decoupling
between
your various actors and guarantee and is
able to then guarantee this thread
safety
that we talked about and that only one
message is handled at a time
so what i get back is a actor id that
actor id is then what we use
to send an event
and here we're gonna send up to five
random number generation you know one
plus random to five so
we should send one to five messages here
to that greeter and we'll store in this
little variable here count how many
greetings we sent
now notice that the test actor is also
an actor right so just like the greeter
this test actor tells coyote with a
custom attribute what kind
of events it can receive which is this
greeting event
and when it receives a greeting event
call the handle greeting method
handle greeting method is down here
we're able to cast that back to greeting
event
and we decrement the count so here we're
actually going to start
writing some test code we will decrement
the count
and print out what the greeting was just
so we can see it in the log
and we're going to assert that this
count never becomes
negative if it does then we have a
problem that there are too many
greetings returned
of course we've injected a bug in here
on purpose that will return too many
greetings
and so with with a one in ten chance
this program should report that error
so we'll go ahead and build that
and we'll run that version i'll just
bring it over to our
console window
run it like this when you run a coyote
program like this
outside the coyote tester we call that
running in production
this is exactly what you would do with a
production coyote program
you just run it like any other c-sharp
program
iot is just a library that is loaded in
the process
so we've run it once we've run it twice
this time we got five greetings
and so far we haven't seen that bug
because there's only a 1 in 10 chance
we'll ever actually
get that bug in fact there we go finally
so i had to run it a lot of times
manually so this is
the thing with non-determinism you'll
typically find yourself having to run a
lot of iterations before
you actually trigger the bug that you're
looking for
and then when you get the bug how do you
reproduce it it's so hard to reproduce
in the first place
all right so let's run this in coyote
i did with the other one
we'll run coyote
test
and we have to have the same.net
platform so we'll run the 46 version
we just ran one iteration but let's run
100 iterations
oh found the bug right away in that case
but let's do it again
and again you can see it's finding the
bug really quickly every time i run this
and
again as before there's a log file this
time the log file is a little bit more
interesting because it's showing you
more of the coyote actor runtime
activity including messages when they
uh sent so we can see a whole bunch of
send operations
and then as the messages get dequeued
and uh
executed by an action on the greeter so
this is the handle greeting action
and then finally we see the assert too
many greetings returned
which was triggered by that assert
again we can replay this as well just as
before
and we can get the uh 100 reproducible
bug now um let's take a look at a bigger
example we have
the coffee machine example where we also
have an
asynchronous version of the coffee
machine up here on github using
asynctasks
right here and you can look into that um
in your own time
but if you check out the code you'll see
that the task-based version of the copy
machine
is using a lot of locks and even needs
async box
in order to get its state correct
the actor version is lock free
and that's the one i want to look at in
a little bit more detail here
so what is this copy machine example
about
coffee machine example shows you how to
build a state machine
so coyote actors not only provide an
actor model but they provide a
first-class
state machine model so this is a fun
little coffee machine that i have in my
kitchen
and oh that reminds me i need some
coffee
very good um and
it has a state machine so what does it
do
that coffee machine first of all when
you boot it up it
checks the state of everything what's
the water level what's the coffee level
and and it has a water heater of course
it's got to heat up its water
so it can make steam and it's monitoring
that when it's ready
you can press the make coffee button and
it'll run the grinder which will grind
the beans
it will then fill up that little filter
thing that pumps the water through
starts making shots the shots come out
at the bottom and of course
some things can go wrong as in always
with machines
so you can run out of water and a refill
is required and this machine is
obviously you need a manual refilling
process for both for coffee beans and
for water
and otherwise if everything's good it
can clean itself up
and go back to the ready state this is
all implemented in the coffee machine
example
using coyote actor programming model
let's take a look at that in
visual studio
machine actors
all right so the coffee machine
actors has a coffee machine
and this is a new concept
in coyote that i haven't talked about
yet which is state machines
a state machine in coyote is a special
type of actor
that understands all of those states
that you saw
in that state diagram
now in a state machine what you do is
you
declare so it's also declarative
you declare the states of the machine
with a class that's that inherits from
the coyote state
base class state is a nested class
inside state machine
so this is telling coyote that this
class has a
state called check senses now remember
with act with actors regular actors
these were all at the class level
but now with state machines we can move
that down into
the state level so for each state you
can declare
what events are valid what can you do
when you're in that state
you can also tell coyote to defer
certain states so don't try to make a
coffee yet because we're not ready
you can also have a special event that
happens when we enter
the state so this is like a setup
piece of code that happens when we enter
the check sensor state
what do we do well what can we do with
with actors we can send events
so what do we do we send events to the
coffee grinder and we tell it to turn
off the coffee grinder we turn off the
water pump we turn off the water heater
we also re send some reed events over to
those various sensors
to read the water level read the hobby
level because we want to make sure at
the beginning of this state machine that
every all the sensors are in a good
state
that we actually have water that we can
make coffee and so on
so since we sent these read requests
that's why we're getting
back four read responses basically these
are the four events that we're expecting
back
these can all happen completely
asynchronously depending on
thread scheduling but our code
is is handling those events so here's an
example of
when we get back the water level we
handle that right here
we get a water level we store it in a
local member variable we print it out
and we check to see if the water level
is empty if it's empty
then we have to go to a different state
and here you can see a
more state machinery showing up where we
tell coyote that we're going to
transition
to a different state this can be done
either in code
and it can also be done declaratively i
don't think there's an example of that
on
here but let's see on event
go to right there's a declarative way of
saying
when the make coffee if we're in the
ready state and somebody
presses the make coffee button then
we can just go straight to the make
coffee state so this is something that's
completely handled by the coyote run
timers we don't even have to write any
code
to do that state transition to making
coffee
and then when we start making coffee
that's when the really interesting stuff
happens we grind the beans
we go into grinding bean state and so on
and so forth so you can see how that
state machine is progressing
throughout this code here the
sensors then is is this is called mock
sensors because
this is not the real machine obviously
this is not the actual firmware of the
of the real machine this is this is
built just for testing
we have monitors which i'll get into in
a little bit but we have the door sensor
we have the
water tank and these are all just simple
actors these
these are simple enough that it didn't
need to use the state machine model it
can just
be a simple actor so the water tank can
register a client that it can talk to it
can
read the water level as you saw earlier
you can read the water temperature
you can actually turn on the water
heater
and there's a timer concept so coyote
actors also support
timers which is a callback a you know
frequent callback
event that can happen automatically
and then you can pump the water to make
a coffee and so on and so forth there's
another timer
involved there so this is a an example
of a
mock implementation of an actor that's
implementing the uh
logic behind the sensors and the
hardware of the coffee machine
the coffee machine class then is more
like the cpu of the coffee machine it's
the thing that coordinates all that
hardware
and makes the machine actually work
now upper level here we have a failover
driver so this sample is
more than just showing you how state
machines work this sample is going to do
one more really interesting thing
to test that our code is ready for prime
time we're going to
reboot the copy machine so imagine if
the little tiny cpu inside the coffee
machine glitched out and rebooted
halfway through making a coffee what bad
things could happen with that
and obviously if you're not careful in
how you write that code
it could do all kinds of silly things
and then what we do is we
have some assertions in the code things
that we want to verify
never happen for example do not turn on
the water heater if there's no water
uh bad things could happen burn down
your house do not
uh turn on the coffee grinder if there's
no beans in the hopper
can that that can ruin the grinder um
don't try to make a shot if there's no
water and so on there's also a safety
feature if the door is open
the machine has to not do anything i
don't want fingers getting stuck in
there
so these are safety asserts that you'll
see throughout the sample code
and shows how coyote can help ensure
that these assets are always true
during testing even during failover
testing so
we're going to boot up one coffee
machine it's going to get halfway
through its process and then we're going
to kill it
just like that and then we're going to
start another coffee machine and what
this test is proving
is that the code is is hardened to
fail and handle failover nicely the new
coffee machine when it boots up
needs to verify all of the sensor states
relearn what's happening and make sure
it doesn't do something silly
when you build this program it's still
just a very simple console program
and we get this here and there'll be a
bunch of print statements that show you
what the coffee machine
is doing if we run that
over here
all right right off the bat is we can
see that it detected that the door was
open
great so the door was open which you can
see in red
the mock sensors because those are test
classes do actually initialize the
machine with random states
so the door sensor randomly chooses to
be open or not
the water levels are randomly set and
the temperatures are set the coffee
levels are random
and that also helps the testing of this
program discover
more of these fault cases so that was
interesting we hit the uh
we hit the error case right off the bat
this time this time it's off and making
coffee however
we started off with random water levels
and coffee levels that were very low
so these are very low numbers it did
heat up that water
which is fun and it started making
coffee so it started grinding beans and
started filling up the portafilter but
then it ran out of coffee beans halfway
through
so automatically it went to an error
state at that point
the coffee machine is done there's
nothing more can be
that you can do with this test without
restarting the test
until we manually refill the coffee
machine let's see if we can find a run
that actually goes all the way to making
coffee
no that one's empty and this one looks
good it's got a higher
higher levels there so it's making shots
in a mix of coffee
great all the way to three shots
completed so
the first round of running that coffee
machine
worked now remember all the events
flying around between the
coffee machine and those mock sensor
hardware objects
all asynchronous so this is a very
asynchronous program
all right so it will keep running until
it runs out of resources but the
question now is
how can we test every possible
interleaving of all of those events
and see if there are any bugs in the
code we actually did inject a bug in the
code
and we haven't hit it yet in fact you
can run it like this all day long and
you probably never hit
the bug that we've injected in the code
so
again we'll run this in the coyote test
tool to see what happens
party test tool has some more options
besides iterations
i can also tell it what are the max
steps
so for each iteration you can explore
but what if your program is just an
infinite program you have to tell it to
stop somewhere
otherwise the kodi tester will just get
stuck in exploring an
infinite state of of transitions and so
what you can do is you can say max steps
and let's say max steps is 500 there's
no more
you know no point testing more than 500
events at a time
for each iteration you can also use
different scheduling algorithms so
coyote like remember i said that
microsoft research has built
some a bunch of different search
algorithms
and you can actually specify the search
algorithm that you want to use in a test
and this is called pct
there's a lot more documentation on that
online what that means
but i'll go ahead and run that so here
it is setting up
everything iteration one two three four
and it found a bug
all right surprise surprise i know we
put it in on purpose
let's take a look at the log file
and now this is more interesting this is
a real system this is not just hello
world and so what we see now
as a page down here is you know
600 events before we found a bug
and this triggered this was an assert
that triggered that said please do not
turn on the grinder if there's no beans
in the in the hopper so with this
failover experiment where we killed one
machine started another machine we're
making coffee
all throughout this we actually found a
bug where it did
try to turn on the grinder when there
were no beans so there's definitely a
bug in here
so the fun part of this exercise then is
to
try to find that bug um
[Music]
i'll let you do that in your own time
the other thing you can do with this
test
is you can ask for graph now i'm going
to ask for graph of just the one
iteration
that contained the bug and because
of all of that declarative state
machinery around states and events that
can be received and so on
there's a very cool feature that's
provided by curie which is
producing a dgml diagram dgml can be
visualized using visual studio so here
we go
this is a visualization of all the
states and state transitions that
happened i'm going to press ctrl
a to see everything that happened here
so all of these links that are
connecting these nodes are messages that
flowed
across these actors and state machines
you can see that a coffee machine was
created here
number five and it went all the way
through making grinding making shots and
cleaning up so this
actually completed a full iteration of
making coffee
then it was halted by the failover
driver remember we said we're going to
kill the cafe machines here we've killed
the coffee machine
and we create a new one the new coffee
machine started up and went all the way
through to grinding beans where it hit
the assert
that said hey hang on there's no beans
in the hopper so
that's the bug it should never have gone
that far it should have got to
check sensors and check sensors should
have said hey there's no coffee beans so
what happened
but this helps us visualize uh what's
going on here and in fact the diagram
animation that i showed you on the web
page
with the raft protocol was built from
these
diagrams all right
so this is also a super useful way to
just look at the design of your program
to communicate that design to other
people on the team
and to you know visually see what's
going on in a complex system
which can also be very useful so you can
see now that coyote is more than a test
tool it's
it's a test tool that integrates with
your development process by providing
frameworks and
declarative ways of declaring states and
so on and it integrates with your design
process in the sense that you can now
see what your program is doing
and reason about it
i glossed over quickly in that state
machine example there is also a monitor
and the monitor is a type of state
machine
that is um a passive
listener in a sense that a monitor can
receive events but it shouldn't be
sending events to other
parts of the system so it's just there
uh oftentimes you'll run
monitors only in test time and not a
production time if you don't want the
overhead of monitoring
stuff and the monitor is something that
coyote
also supports some really cool concepts
including a liveness monitor and let me
show you the code for that
we have a liveness monitor in the coffee
machine and what does that mean what are
we looking for with a liveness monitor
a liveness monitor is something that has
cold states
and hot states and these are two custom
attributes that are only available on
monitors and coyote will
make sure that your monitor doesn't get
stuck
in the hot state what this means the way
this can be used in the coffee machine
is we're trying to verify that the
coffee machine always gets the job done
with async programs where you can easily
get stuck in this circular event storms
and this guy sends an event which sends
an event which sends an event and you
get this big you know
ladder effect it's sometimes hard to
prove that your program is ever actually
going to finish
and i've actually seen this program this
problem happened with real commercial
large systems where they get stuck in
event storms and they never finish the
job
so it's a hard problem so the liveness
monitor is a tool that you can use with
coyote
to verify that your machine always
finishes the job it has to either
make the coffee or report an error that
it needs refilling but it
it should never get stuck in some
intermediate state of just going round
and round and round
and coyote will actually verify this at
test time
and it has an algorithm that determines
if it's spent too much time in
in the hot state coyote will raise an
assert automatically saying hey
you've got a problem the door safety
monitor is a different kind of monitor
it's not a liveness monitor so it
doesn't use
hot and cold states instead it's just a
global
thing that's monitoring busy events from
the cafe machine
and the door open event so it remembers
if there's a door open event
that we should go to the error state and
when we're in the error state
if we ever get any indication from the
coffee machine that is doing something
then it shouldn't be and that's an error
so we can assert right off the bat hey
if the coffee machine started doing
something while the door was open
this should never happen and so that's
another
way of writing monitors using coyote
you can run them at test time or some
people actually do choose to run
monitors in production as well
all right so now let's move it up a
level to something even more
real and this is the original example
that i showed you
which is the implementation of the raft
cluster
protocol okay and
raft is often used for fault tolerant
clusters so what we've done
in this example called cloud messaging
is we've provided four projects
that use coyote here's actually
since we're on this page i'll take the
opportunity to show a classic state
machine here
all implemented with states so now you
can sort of with a
really clear glance at this code you can
see
the kind of state machinery that's going
on in this class you don't have to kind
of reverse engineer it by looking at all
the member variables and how those
member variables are
sprinkled and around all of your code
it's a very clear declaration of a state
machine
all right so the four projects in this
solution
the raft project over here is just the
c library that uses coyote doesn't know
anything about azure
it's a pure implementation of the raft
server protocol so that's what this
class is
and the raft server is a state machine
but again like i said this doesn't know
anything about azure
it sends messages and uh receives
messages
and implements the wrath protocol you
can see there's quite a lot of code here
um there's a really great website online
that explains the raft protocol how it
works it's quite intricate
and of course if you're building a fault
tolerant cluster of services you really
want to know that that code is correct
so that's why it's really important to
test this with coyote
the how do servers talk to other servers
so in a true
distributed system you're going to have
some sort of message bus
you're going to have some messaging
system that can that send messages
across machines
now coyote is not in the business of
providing a messaging platform kaity is
not
one of those things it doesn't compete
with service but it doesn't compete with
any messaging system cody is just an
abstraction on top of that
so um what we've done here is we've
modeled
the cluster concept the pub sub concept
if you like so
a server can send a message to all the
other servers is a pub sub
concept we've modeled that as a state
machine
using uh coyote so we've created this
cluster manager but this is going to be
an abstract
class with no implementations you can
see here that
it doesn't actually implement anything
it's expected that either your test will
implement something or your true
azure deployment will plug in here how
to
broadcast a vote request across that pub
sub system
and in the uh raft azure project
you'll actually see an azure cluster
manager that's implemented using the
service bus topic client api so if
you're familiar with azure
service bus it provides a concept of
topics topics are a pub
sub concept where you have a topic
client that can send
messages and you have a topic receiver
a message receiver in from the service
bus that can receive those
pub sub messages so this is how we've
plugged into
the azure service bus and when we
receive messages
we can see we have to pass json all that
kind of stuff stuff coyote doesn't care
about
what really matters is at some point you
get the coyote actor run time
and you call send event so there we
we've gone from send event out to a pub
sub system the pub sub system has
brought that message back
in and then we push it back into the
coyote world
if you like so we've kind of plugged
azure back into this coyote world
but we've kept it a very clean
separation and the reason why that clean
separation is
good is when you get to the mocking
version of this program
where we want to test this thing so
the mock version has a mock client that
sends events to the servers so this is
how we
request work to be done by that cluster
we have a mock cluster manager that
doesn't know about azure service bus so
the
mock cluster manager is is just a very
simple you know broadcast is a very
simple for loop over a list of servers
where that list of servers
is a bunch of actor ids so it's a for
loop
just send it to all the other guys um
except for us you know the guy who
is sending this request um and
uh so the mock implementation of the
cluster managers all runs locally
in the same process even or across you
know if you run it locally you can run
it in multiple processes but
um but this one is is actually going to
run the whole test
in one process which means that coyote
can run really really fast when coyote
is testing this rap protocol
it doesn't have to wait for us service
bus events right it can it can run
thousands of times faster in memory on
one machine
it's also super convenient for a
developer to be able to test all of
their code
in isolation on one machine before they
try to push it into production
all right so let's go ahead and build
that
and i won't run the azure version
because that needs a service bus
account setup and all that kind of stuff
you can see there's a setup script that
will do that
uh in the tutorial you're certainly
welcome to go ahead and run that prove
that it works with azure service bus
provider connection strings on the
command line and so forth but what i'm
going to run
is the mock version of this and see if
it can find any bugs
this is actually a picture that after i
ran this i was using the same
graphing capability to look at what
happened in the state machine
at test time so here you can see
this is actually a different type of
graph that's called a coverage graph so
it doesn't show
all five servers instead it collapses
each instance
into one group to just show you code
coverage so it's kind of like showing
you what
what are all the things that happened
across all 100 or 1000 iterations
for testing this thing and i'll show you
how that works
right here so i'm going to run the same
[Music]
priority test tool except this time i'm
going to use
net 47.
we can also support.net core which means
coyote is also cross-platform you can
run that on any system that has.net core
and i'm going to test the bin
at 47 raft.moc
dll now uh i'm going to test a thousand
iterations well let's
let's do 100 iterations with max steps
of 200
steps per iteration and i'm going to
request that coverage graph
and um and that's activity
coverage so this is different from code
coverage it's a higher level concept of
coverage which is
at that event level were all the events
that were declared sent and received by
all the various places that said they
could receive events so it's like an
event
coverage graph so i went ahead and it
ran
100 iterations didn't find any bugs in
this case which is expected because we
didn't put any bugs in it
yet and uh and there's your diagram
and very similar to the version we saw
before
let me get rid of that
okay and control a
i can see events were sent across these
things
so there's an event here a state machine
timer sent a time elapsed event
the cluster manager sent events and so
on
so the implementation of the raf
protocol does in fact involve these four
states
and you can read about what those states
mean on the web page
description of this tutorial but you can
see it's actually reaching all the
states
most importantly for this test we want
to see that one of the servers at some
point reached the leader state
and this can also be a liveness problem
if no servers ever
reach the leader state then it means
they're just jostling and justly and
justly for leader but nobody's actually
getting it
that would be a liveness problem uh with
your cluster so it's great to see that
during this test the leader state was
achieved
all right
so remember uh coyote can help you with
non-determinism so we have a
fourth example in a fourth project in
that solution
which is called raft non-determinism
where we can actually start to model
some non-deterministic behavior so
oftentimes when you build a mock using
coyote what you want to do is capture
some of the weird behaviors of some
external system that you have to deal
with
and in this case we've modeled a
situation where
the non-deterministic behavior is that
somewhere in our messaging system
whatever messaging system that is we end
up
getting duplicate events uh another
thing you might model is
events get lost and never get delivered
but in this case we're gonna
we're gonna model the non-deterministic
problem
that we're struggling with is our system
can't handle it when
we get duplicate events so let's
take a look at that code just quickly
the way we do that in raf.nondeterminism
is we inject a special implementation of
the cluster manager
where that cluster manager
is going to randomly decide based on
this random boolean
to send an event twice so we get
duplicates
what's that going to do to the server
and is the server
going to uh you know the implementation
of the raf protocol going
going to be able to handle that without
without any problems
um and we can run
raf.nondeterminism like before
that and it's going to go ahead and
search for
for bugs we've asked for 100 iterations
and we'll see what happens
didn't find any bugs found zero bugs
all right so what i happen to know uh is
that this bug is
particularly hard to reproduce
the in other words the servers are are
quite good
the server implementation is is really
good uh
but i guarantee you there is a bug in
there so now i'm going to show you
another feature of coyote which is that
you can also ask for
um
[Music]
a whole collection of different
scheduling algorithms remember those
search algorithms
portfolio so this is telling coyote
don't just use one uh scheduling
algorithm algorithm but
test your throat throw lots of different
scheduling algorithms at this problem
and even better let's run
eight tests at once in parallel in
different processes
so this is going to fire up eight
processes on my box
and it's probably gonna kill my poor
little laptop let's see what happens
and um i'll ask for five then and
it's going to give each one of those
processes a different random
scheduling algorithm and then we're
going to search so here we see it
launching
all five of those processes
and it starts firing up it's got
probabilistic it's got random fair pct
so there's your random selection of
search algorithms if you like
off it goes running running running
and it found no bugs but the cool thing
is
with these really hard bugs i can
increase their max steps and i can
increase
the number of iterations i can you know
kyrie is doing all the hard work for me
i can i can
run a million iterations and go have a
coffee right and then come back and i've
got the bug
and then i can tell my manager how
wonderful i am that i can find bugs like
that
it'll help your career
and i'll let that run off in the
background and we'll come back and check
it later and see
if it found a bug
all right so that's the end of my talk
and
what we really want is your input on
this i think you'll agree so far that
coyote is a powerful tool it can help
you grapple with concurrency and
non-determinism
it's available now both as a nuget
package and
as source code on github and
this uh if you go up there and take a
look at the website you'll see that
there are more examples as well like
this one
uh robots so if that's your your fun
topic there's a really fun
tutorial here that will show you how
we've used coyote to help a robot
navigate around a room
so that thing was running in the
background and it found a bug
and we can see that there's a log file
and this log file
now is huge
it contains 6
700 events and it found a bug and the
bug is that there was
more than one leader elected in the
cluster at one time
which is breaks the protocol you can't
have a fault tolerant cluster
if two servers are competing for the
same job
so um there you see it found a bug
and we also see the replayable schedule
so
again now in a real system the replay
feature becomes huge right so it took a
long time to find this bug
but when i replay this using that replay
schedule
using the replay command
it'll only have to run those 6000
messages so it should be a lot quicker
than it was the first time so it took 14
seconds the first time
uh the replay should be a lot quicker
and of course with the replay i can
i can put that in a debugger i can put
breakpoints everywhere i can step
through it as slowly as i want i don't
care
need to care about that interfering with
the timing of everything
it will reproduce the bug 100 guaranteed
and you can find the bug and fix it
we'll try to answer your questions and
issues as quickly as we can
if you post them up on the github issues
list we also have a getter account
there for coyote and a stack overflow
tag so feel free
post your questions there and
we look forward to hearing from you
thank you very much
thanks everybody for joining the webinar
this is chris lovett and i'm also
had a lot of help during the question
and answer time
from my colleagues akash and fantasies
we got a lot of really good deep
questions today so
i'll go over some of the most
interesting questions that we saw
the first one was is this a testing tool
or a programming framework and that's a
really great question because
coyote is is this interesting thing
that's both
it's it's a programming framework that
helps
guide you in a way that you create code
that can be tested really well
using the coyote test tool i would go
even further to say that coyote is even
a design tool because it gives you these
visualizations and ways of
of looking at how your code is working
so
that's a great question thanks thanks
for that one another question that
showed up quite a bit
uh and we've heard this before is
what's the difference between coyote
orleans and service fabric because they
all
seem to have this actor model and
you know so why do we have so many actor
models is a common question
and the answer to that is that orleans
and service fabric
are much more than coyote those are
distributed runtimes they actually will
take the job of delivering messages
over a distributed network
they give you all of the machinery for
reliable messaging
for you know pub sub all that sort of
stuff
and coyote isn't any of that coyote is
just
a programming library just like the task
parallel library in the
net frameworks it's not a distributed
runtime
coyote can be used actually inside of
service fabric or inside of an orleans
grain you could actually use coyotes
programming framework
but so so they can be complementary
they're not
it's not coyote is not attempting to
compete with orleans or service fabric
at all uh coyote is just about how you
write your logic and how you test that
let's see what other interesting
questions do we have here
i think uh there was a great question
about
uh the coffee machine and
and how to you know test
systems the question was why not test
each individual machine in a coffee
machine
separately is the guidance that the test
should serve
to test an overall user scenario
so by putting multiple machines together
and this is this is
uh you know the answer and what you saw
during the webinar
uh you can test how those machines are
actually interacting with each other so
you
actually get a deeper sort of test
coverage of how
you know events from one machine trigger
state changes in another machine
and so that gives you actually a more
interesting
test you can test each machine
independently if you want to
and by mocking everything else in a in a
truly
big and distributed system you probably
need to do that
uh where you focus on one part of your
system and
mock everything else and you can
actually use coyote to
to create those mocks we actually do
that
in the azure example the um cloud
messaging example
we use mocking of the back end service
bus
because you don't want to be running the
coyote test
and waiting for messages to be delivered
through azure so you actually can mock
out the service bus and test the logic
uh
all in memory on your laptop so you can
you can do it both ways but we showed
the copy machine example that way
because it's it's it's also shows the
value of
uh being able to test multiple machines
you know in memory
exploring all of those state transitions
that that becomes quite a large
uh state space to explore all of that
and cody can do that
so another question was there's a lot of
mention
of azure you know i assume that we can
run coyote
you know on-prem as well and absolutely
true
uh coyote actually the if you look at
the coyote source code on github you'll
see that there's
zero dependencies on azure in fact
coyote has
a very small number of dependencies
and we keep it that way on purpose
because we want coyote to be generally
as useful as possible in as many
different situations as possible so
coyote has
a very very small number of dependencies
uh just barely on top of the dot net
frameworks
so
all of the demos that i showed in the
webinar in fact were actually running
on my laptop literally my surface laptop
right here
and uh so you can certainly run coyote
uh
like that and and i think that's that
fits the developers
you know habits really well because you
want to be able to test and
your system in isolation on your dev box
and
get all of those bugs found before you
push any code
into a big distributed you know online
cloud system
so coyote is designed to be used that
way all right
uh let's see one last question
will coyote be part of the.net framework
release
can developers be assured it will be
supported for the foreseeable future by
microsoft
before they integrate it into their
software and this is yes this is a great
question
um i would love to see coyote integrated
into the net frameworks
because i don't own the.net frameworks
so i cannot make any claims that that
will ever happen
and i think it would be awesome if you
think that should happen
maybe you should tell the.net framework
team that's what you want
but you know obviously the dyna
frameworks have to be extremely careful
about what they put in there because
they
they do have to support it for all time
um so
while coyote came out of microsoft
research it is actually in the process
of of an incubation process right now
where it's actually
being productized much more than most
research projects in fact coyote is
heavily used by internal azure teams and
and so it's
it's probably going to stick around for
a long time just even if it's just
because of that
but in reality you know uh researchers
research
uh we can't guarantee that this will
become a product like the dotnet
frameworks
so that's one reason why we made it an
open source project on github
and that ensures that github can take on
a coyote can take on a life of its own
um with an active community the code is
there people
can submit pull requests we actually
welcome that we would love to see
people uh uh submitting pull requests
issues post issues up there and you'll
see us
responding to that as quickly as we can
we want coyote to succeed we want
everyone to benefit from it so
we we hope it sticks around for a long
time so with that i'll
i'll wrap it up and i'll thank everybody
for joining the webinar
and uh again feel free to participate
with coyote
on github thank you very much
you